welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and thrawn has arrived in live
action exiled on peridia with a legion
of Scruffy night Troopers in a trio of
witches and while Lars Mickelson is
bringing back that ASMR purr from
voicing the character in Rebels stock
magic what's most interesting about him
is the way time has taken its toll on
this Imperial Grand Admiral known in
some corners of the internet as the
chiseled chest and a tank top now he has
a uniformed frayed and wrinkled in some
spots in a new interest in fate and
destiny that sounds curious coming from
an empirical War strategist who didn't
really seem too interested in
Superstition who's only ever is
interested in that kind of thing as his
enemies were as someone who always
studied his enemies histories and arts
and beliefs and upon doing some digging
into thrawn's past I realize there's
actually a fascinating reason he's
obsessed with fate and now surrounding
himself with three witches named after
the fates of Greek mythology it's
because thrawn is terrified of how he's
going to die and he is barreling toward
that nightmarish end anyway whether he's
aware of it or not so in Ahsoka episode
6 thrawn Star Destroyer the chimere
arrives on peridia and Saddles up on
that Witch Tower reverse cowgirl the
Chimera thrawn and his Stormtroopers are
all in rough shape missing pieces
augmented with spare parts and red
Knight sister straps but still our man
is brimming with cultish pride thrawn
has forged an Unholy alliance with three
witches the great mothers named clothol
lakesis and actropod named directly
after the three fates of Greek mythology
who spin measure and cut the thread of
Fate for each life with episode 2 titled
toil and trouble this series also wants
us to think about the three witches or
weird sisters from Shakespeare's Macbeth
who similarly counsel Macbeth with
prophetic visions of the future that
Macbeth followed to both his fortune and
to his folly back in episode 2 Morgan
Elizabeth told Balin skull and shinhati
this the threats of Fate do not lie and
that thread terminology returns with the
great mothers in episode 6 when they
inform thrawn about Sabine joining
Morgan Balin and shin you never spoke of
this we did not see it it is a loose
threat well speak to me if this loose
threat loose thread a thread that they
couldn't measure or cut because they
didn't see it coming it was not part of
their tapestry and so throughout this
episode thrawn regards Sabine with a bit
of uncertainty and trepidation This
Thread language actually comes back at
the end of the episode the threat of
Fate has spoken to us they report a new
Jedi approaches enthron tells Morgan
that death and Resurrection are common
deceptions played out by both night
sisters and Jedi and turned back to
these witches great mothers I should
once again require the aid of your dark
magic the thread of Destiny demands it
Grand Admiral yes they say the threat of
Destiny demands it they want to supply
their dark magic they think they have to
I'd mentioned the theory that the
coffins they're transporting might
contain the corpses of Knight Brothers
and night sisters that they plan to
reanimate and that these scruffy
Stormtroopers might be the night
Troopers zombies in their own rights
their bodies held together with these
red straps thrawn mentioned that their
numbers are dwindling and he denies
Morgan's request for more backup to
Balin and Chin limiting to just two
units of these night Troopers we think
so where does thrawn's fear in obsession
with fate come from well if you watched
our Rebel recap series if you haven't
already definitely do so it'll make you
love Ahsoka even more but if you watch
Rebels you know that season 3 ends with
a mysterious Force sensitive being a
Bindu on the planet atalan intervening
in thrawn's assault on the rebel base
bendu goes full moon FASA on them the
rebels Escape but thrawn blast them out
of the clouds and it ends with this
fascinating exchange between bendu and
thrawn what
creature are you one beyond your power
to destroy it would not seem so one
beyond your power to destroy so we
aren't really seeing bendu's death here
we're really just seeing his kind of
transference or his teleportation back
into the cosmos bendu cannot be killed
through conventional means he goes on
you cannot see but I can what what do
you see I see your defeat like many arms
surrounding you in a cold Embrace of
course this would foreshadow thrawn's
eventual defeat in the cold Embrace of
the many arms of the pergol or so we
think habits get a bad rap but not all
habits are created equal brushing your
teeth a good habit Doom scrolling bad
habit but if you want to turn your bad
habits into good ones you use fume fume
is an Innovative award-winning device
with no electronics no Vapor no harmful
chemicals fume is completely natural it
uses all natural ingredients to give you
a burst of delicious flavored air I
recently just opened a pack of the cores
they smell really nice very refreshing
fume makes it possible to have a habit
you're free to enjoy and makes replacing
your bad habit easy Doom comes with
adjustable airflow dial and is designed
with these movable parts and magnets
it's super fidgety which is helpful for
de-stressing while you break your old
habit using fume is like having a breath
of fresh minty air or fresh peppery air
it's a nice moment just for you and
taking a moment for yourself is a good
habit trust me over 100 000 people have
used fume to successfully break out of
bad habits and now you can too switching
to fume is easy just head to tryfume.com
and use code new rockstars to save 10
off when you get the journey pack today
that's try fum and use code new
rockstars to save an additional 10 off
your order today we all assumed that
bendu was foreseen the series finale
with the Pergo but now that thrawn is
returned alive and Ahsoka that reframes
this big mom moment with bendu yes bendu
said defeat not death and thrawn's
victory being stature with hyperspace
whales was objectively a defeat or a
setback for him but we don't know
exactly what happened when thrawn and
Ezra entered that Pergo hyperspace
because the windows of the Chimera
Bridge were broken could the people
there breathe with their atmosphere
exposed to Portable hyperspace just
baloney think about that like it kind of
seems like they don't have to scramble
off the bridge real fast maybe as we're
doing some like force floating making
their way to an airlocked part of the
Chimera and just holding tight Ezra I
guess could have used his time to run
around the Chimera hiding from thrawn
and his forces and then when the Pergo
left hyperspace would they be within the
atmosphere paridia probably not they'd
be like outside of it in open exposed
space so then I guess the Pergo would
like fling the Chimera down to the
peridian surface and then I guess Ezra
could have snuck out of that wreckage
and then eventually found his way to the
no T and then thrawn spent nine years
trying to find him where's Ezra
yeah it's all a little unclear but based
on where thrawn is now I just think he
would consider his current status as
undefeated or at least not yet defeated
he was exiled but his ego seems to be
unscathed if anything he was transported
to a place where he now has witches
loyal to him but what's going on beneath
the surface because like our beloved
heroes in every Final Destination film
that I know we've all seen all of thrawn
may feel like he cheated death and that
Specter is still hanging over him that
could be why he's so obsessed with these
Destiny reports from the great mothers
so if the many arms and the cold Embrace
that bendu referred to weren't the
pergol I mean the pergol or whales
they're probably warm-blooded right what
was bendu referring to in that moment
the question must keep thrawn awake
every night and now that question has
been wholly redefined that prophecy
could refer to something we have not
seen yet now we should acknowledge that
thrawn probably isn't gonna die in this
Ahsoka series at least I hope not
because Beyond this Dave filoni has been
confirmed to direct a feature film for
lucasfilm at some point in the future
that is meant to be the culmination of
all these new Republic Pre-Sequel
Trilogy era Stories the Mandalorian the
book of Boba Fett Ahsoka Skeleton Crew
and I think we can assume that thrawn
will be the villain of that film which
would mean that thrawn could return as a
villain or a background figure in future
seasons of these shows that come out
before that film does but this loose
thread with bendu must have thrawn
pretty nervous about working with an
army of the Dead Stormtroopers that look
a lot like night Troopers could the many
hands and the cold embrace come from
night sister sorcery backfiring on
thrawn similar to how the night sisters
made a deal with the separatists during
the Clone Wars era that ended with old
DACA and mother towels and resurrecting
an army of the Dead against Dooku and
Grievous could thrawn suffer a similar
fate you know our man's worried about
that please support our Channel by
grabbing one of these fulcrum shirts
from nerd riot.shop and please subscribe
to all three channels including the
break room which has our Wikileaks
Ahsoka after show follow me on our
social platforms at eavos and I'll see
you next time bye everybody
[Music]
thank you